Okay.
Bitte schön.
Ja.
Hallo Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Aydin.
Ich bin hier erst seit ersten Tag und heute für diese Ausstellung.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwurz führen.
Ich werde zuerst ein Parkour und so irrepresentationen stellen.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Mein Name ist Wolfgang Schmidt.
Wolfgang Schmidt.
Schmidt mit DT.
Mit DT.
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50?
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 groß und 76 kg schwer.
76 kg schwer.
Okay.
Danke sehr.
Herr Schmidt, was für ein Bescheid?
Ich bin heute Abend mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs gewesen.
Es war draußen nass.
Es hat geregnet.
Ich bin um die Kurve mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Nach einer Zeit,
nach einer Zeit,
mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Nach rechts abgewogen.
Dabei bin ich ausgerutscht und gestürzt.
Ich habe mich verletzt.
Ich wurde mit einem Krankenwagen hergebracht.
Ich hoffe, dass alles Gute ist.
Okay.
Ich hoffe auch.
Herr Schmidt, Sie haben wegen dem Fahrrad ausgerutscht.
Ich war mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs.
Sind Sie auf der rechten Seite hingefahren?
Ja, auf der rechten Seite.
Mir tut ein rechter Handgelenk weh.
Mein rechter Knie.
Und dieser Lenkrad von dem Fahrrad
ist auch über einen Bauch reingeschraubt.
Da habe ich es nicht stark geschmessen,
aber da tut es mir auch ein bisschen weh.
Wo sind diese Schmerzen am stärksten?
Im rechten Handgelenk tut es am meisten weh.
Aber Sie haben Bauchschmerzen.
Leicht.
Wenn man dort lokal drückt, tut es weh.
Wenn man nichts macht, ist es nicht weh.
Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen im Bauch?
Rechte Seite oder linke Seite?
Das ist meine rechte Bauchhälfte.
Rechts.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihr Bewußlein verloren?
Nein, kurz vor dem Nächten.
Ich kann mich genau erinnern.
Es ging zwar alles schnell,
aber ich weiß, wie das wiederumfällt.
Hatten Sie eine Bewußlein?
Ja, beim Fahrradfahren habe ich ein Helm angehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie trotzdem Ihren Kopf verletzt?
Nein, mein Helm hat auch keine Schramme bekommen.
Mein Helm ist auch ganz.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihr Brustkopf verletzt?
Haben Sie Ihre größte Schmerzen im Brust?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen im Brust.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen im Brust.
Im Brustbereich habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Oder ist Ihnen schwarz von Augen?
Nein.
Ich habe nur hauptsächlich Probleme mit meinem rechten Handgelenk.
Der tut mir weh, wenn ich den versuche zu bewegen.
Okay.
Ich verstehe, Herr Schmidt,
dass ich in der
Hand bewegen kann.
Aber bei Bewegung haben Sie Schmerzen.
Genau.
Meine Bewegung ist eingeschränkt.
Ich kann nicht richtig bewegen.
Okay.
Aber ich kann meine Finger bewegen.
Ich kann meine Finger bewegen.
Mein Helm wogend bewegen.
Mein Handgelenk, wenn ich den bewegen möchte, tut es schlag weh.
Okay.
Verstehe.
Ist es Ihnen eine Temperaturunterschied aufgefallen?
Fürklästig, Ihr Hand warm oder kalt?
Oder normal?
Normal, wie die linke Seite.
Okay.
Haben Sie Tatar in Ihrem Handgelenk?
Ja, meine Finger, alle Finger krippeln ein bisschen.
Aber ich kann alles empfinden.
Ist ein bisschen komisch.
So pelzig, kripplich.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt,
wann genau diese Unfall passiert?
Können Sie mir ungefähr sagen?
Ja, ungefähr so eine Vor- und Vor-Siege.
Eine Stunde, okay.
Ja.
Schmerz in Ihrem Schmerz, in irgendwohin aus?
Oder nur in Ihrem rechten Handgelenk?
Sie meinen, die Schmerzen sind jetzt in einem rechten Handgelenk.
Die Schmerzen, nee, das ist lokal.
Der schmerzte Stralp nehmt es so aus.
Okay, ja.
Ja, das ist so.
Können Sie mir sagen, wie stark Ihre Schmerzen sind?
Auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also am Handgelenk, wenn ich nicht bewege,
habe ich einen Schmerz von 1 bis 3.
Und wenn ich bewege, ist es bestimmt 8.
Okay.
Wenn ich nicht bewege, dann?
Ja, und wenn ich bewege, dann?
Ja, okay.
Wie sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Können Sie etwas genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumfer, ziehend, stechend?
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde sagen,
wenn ich das bewege, einstechen der Schmerz.
Aber ansonsten ein dumfer Schmerz.
In Ruhe ein dumfer Schmerz.
Okay, Herr Schinnenkont, Sie hatten keine Chance,
um ein Medikament zu nehmen, oder?
Sie sind hierher mit einem Krankenwagen eingewiesen.
Genau.
Okay, ja.
Herr Schinnenkont, haben Sie irgendeine andere Beschwerde,
außer die Schmerzen?
Ja, also mein Kniegelenk, der tut mir ein bisschen weh,
das ist ein brennendes Gefühl.
Wo die Kniescheibe ist.
Da habe ich auch noch keine Chance, aber vielleicht deswegen,
weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schürfwunde in Ihrem Irgendwäschchen?
An meinem Holhand,
in der Hand-Innenfläche habe ich eine Schürfwunde.
Und an meinem Kniegelenk habe ich auch eine Schürfwunde.
Oberflächlich so eine Schürfwunde.
Das bin ich auch.
Das brennt ein bisschen,
vielleicht ist es ein bisschen tieferer Wunder als im Handgelenk.
Nicht Handgelenk, sondern Hand-Innenfläche.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben keine Blutungen, oder?
Nee, das ist ein bisschen feucht.
Man sieht schon ein bisschen Blut, aber es ist,
aber eine Schürfwunde, aber jetzt nicht so starke Blutung.
Nein, also keine stetige Blutung,
sondern nur ein bisschen blutig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Blutung auflegen, wenn er merkt?
Ja, beklärt nicht.
Dann können Sie ja nachher gucken, wie ich bei Säuntersammeln.
Also ich sehe keine Weile.
Also ich sehe nur eine Schürfwunde in meiner Hand,
in den Flächen und an meinem Knie.
Und mein Bauch tut mir weh,
aber ich sehe keine Schürfwunde.
Okay, okay.
Okay, herrschend.
Ich würde jetzt über Ihren Algemannen Sturzstand,
Gesundheitssturzstand erfahren.
Haben Sie Fiba oder Nachschweiß?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Waselasnode-Schwurtgang?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich habe eigentlich normalerweise keine Probleme.
Aber jetzt habe ich natürlich keinen Bedürfnis.
Okay, okay, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit, sonst ist mein Appetit eigentlich normal.
Haben Sie in der Nessensite geblieben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie irgendeine Schlafprobleme?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Erkrankungen oder Vorerkrankungen herrschend?
Vorerkrankungen, ja.
Ich nehme Medikamente wegen meinen Blutdruck ein
und nehme auch Medikamente wegen meinen Kollisterinspiegel.
Der ist ein bisschen hoch, dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Okay, okay.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen,
aber ich nehme auch Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme einmal Ram-Epril 10 mg ein,
morgens, und Simba Statin 20 mg abends.
20 mg, okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Wo du sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, man hatte, wo ich 15 Jahre alt war,
wo man meine Blutdrucker hatte,
die ich in der Nessensite hatte,
wo man meine Blutdrucker entfernt hatte.
Und das war es schon.
Was ist das? Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie?
Allergie, ja, Polnallergie.
Wie ist diese Allergie bei Ihnen?
Ja, meine Nase läuft
und ich habe die Yukreis auch in meinen Augen.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, auch Corona auch.
Corona auch.
Mein Haus hat mir Impfung, und ich mache alles, was er sagt.
Ich werde trocken.
Was war Ihre letzte Ethetanos-Impfung?
Das war vor zwei Jahren.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Rauchen Sie?
Rauchen? Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal trinke ich mal 2-3 Glas Wein.
Wie oft trinken Sie?
Nur bei Gelegenheit.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich nehme nicht ein.
Trinken Sie Sport, Herr Schmidt?
Sport, ja, ich fahre sehr viel Fahrrad.
Regelmäßig, ja.
Und ich bin im Fitnessstudio und mache Kraftsport.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwann Erkrankungen?
Ich weiß, dass mein Vater auch an Bluthoftok leitet.
Und meine Mutter ist über die Erkrankung.
Ich weiß, dass meine Eltern auch an Bluthoftok leitet.
Und meine Mutter ist über die Erkrankungen.
Und meine Mutter ist übergewichtig.
Und hat auch eine Bluthoftok-Erkrankung.
Okay.
Wie ist sie?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sie ist gesund.
Herr Schmidt, wo ist sie allein?
Oder sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin nicht verheiratet, aber ich bin sehr gesund.
Sie wohnen mit ihr?
Genau, ich wohne seit zehn Jahren mit ihr zusammen.
In einer Wohnung.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Meine Partnerin hat Kinder, mit denen wir zusammen leben.
Aber keine Kinder.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Zollbeamter.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Zollbeamter.
Zollbeamter, okay.
Herr Schmidt, waren Sie unterwegs von Ihrer Arbeit?
Nein, das war in meiner Freizeit gewesen, heute Abend.
Okay.
Ich habe alle Erfolge.
Können Sie etwas zufügen?
Wie geht es weiter?
Was geht mit mir?
Was werden Sie noch machen?
Ich werde jetzt die Köpferlischung versuchen.
Sie haben Ihre Handgelände, Ihre Knie verletzt.
Sie haben auch ein Trauma an Ihrem Bau.
Ich werde Sie überlegen.
Sie haben eine
Ich bin geboren am 1.1.1972.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, Bauchschmerzen und wir müssen die Schmerzen Qualität und Intensität.
Die Schmerzen, wie viel?
Die Schmerzen, auf einer Skala, online, in Dubai, in der der Leichmütze, in der Arschtag, in der Schütze.
Wenn man nichts macht, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Aber wenn man am rechten Bauch rein drückt, dann habe ich Schmerzkala von, würde ich sagen, 4.
Ja.
Durukende Schmerzen?
Ja, so. Ich würde sagen, ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Daverhafte, oda genzi alfide bek.
Die bitte?
Ne, nur wenn Sie draufdrücken, wenn Sie nicht draufdrücken, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ist dann null.
Okay.
Ihre Bauchschmerzen anfangen, 1 Stunde.
Und danach einmal Stuhlgang oder beim Wasser lassen, oder genwind ab?
Also zurzeit habe ich kein Bedürfnis, irgendwie zu verletzen, zu gehen.
Stuhlgang habe ich jetzt auch gerade Bedürfnis, weiß ich nicht.
Gestern, heute Morgen war alles normal.
Ihr Hand haben Sie Kraftlosigkeit?
Kraftlosigkeit würde ich nicht sagen.
Das tut nur weh, wenn ich etwas anfassen möchte.
Nicht, weil ich Kraftlos ist, sondern schmerzhaft.
Das kann ich vielleicht nicht richtig zugreifen.
Okay, das war es.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Man kann auch meinen Knie fragen.
Kann ich meinen Knie bewegen, belasten?
Aber Sie hat gesagt,
Ja, Sie hat gesagt.
Ja, der Patient hat gesagt,
dass ich beim Bewegung abhängig schmerze.
Am Handgelenk.
Aber im Knie.
Aber im Knie habe ich gesagt,
meine Knie vor der Scheibe brennt, das habe ich gesagt.
Aber für den Knie habe ich nicht gesagt, ob ich das bewegen kann.
Ist das Knie geholen?
Ich habe unterhalb des Kniegelenkes irgendwelche Traubarze geholen.
Ja.
Ich habe den Weg schürfen.
Aber man kann ja ausschließen,
ob der Rest auch okay ist.
Ich habe drei Trauben.
Ja, kein Problem.
Ich habe Traume.
Aber wenn Sie fragen,
ich kann meinen Kniegelenk bewegen.
Ich habe den Weg nicht gesamt geschwollen.
Ich kann auch drauf laufen.
Ich habe keine Bewegungseinstehung.
Ich habe nur ein brennendes Gefühl.
Ich habe keine Kräppel und keine Kraftlosigkeit.
Keine Schwedung?
Nur vorne, wo die Wunde geschwollen ist.
Aber nicht.
Da ist nur eine Wunde, die ein bisschen blutig ist.
Sonst ist nichts Auffälliges.
Okay.
Der Patient hat eine Umfall- und Rechthand,
Rechte Bein und Rechte Bauch.
Rechte Knie,
Rechte Handgelenk und ein rechte Bauch.
Ja.
Und Rettungsagentwagen eingegangen.
Ich kam jetzt mit einem Rettungswagen rein.
Wir müssen Vitalparameter überprüfen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich denke, wir müssen Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Das Bauch könnte jetzt zurzeit nicht sein.
Ob eine Wunde am Bauch ist,
das tut nicht weh.
Wenn ich drücke, tut es weh.
Aber es ist nicht weh.
Aber da habe ich keine Schürfwunden.
Herr Matthum hat es gefragt, sehe ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber eine Wunde sehe ich auch nicht.
Eine Schürfwunde.
Wir müssen fragen.
Und eine kleine Minute unterbrechen?
Ja.
Wie?
Was meinen Sie?
Ich werde beschwerden, ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen möchte ich Sie sagen,
ob ich ein Bauch etwas verändert habe.
Deswegen möchte ich
Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Genau.
Das ist jetzt in einem Nese.
Ich werde Sie sofort körperlich untersuchen.
Dann können Sie etwas erwähnen,
was man untersuchen würde.
Wie man vorangehen würde.
Was ich weiß nicht,
ich habe mich schon über die Frage geholfen.
Ich habe mich über die Frage über die Frage geholfen.
Ich habe mich über die Frage geholfen.
Er ist echt giftes.
Habe ich hier wieder eine
hat jemand eben gerade jemand geschrieben, Solbeamter.
Solbeamter.
Dankeschön. Können wir uns als als Geschiebte?
Ja.
Ich kann noch meinerseits ja von der Kollegin.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich werde es.
Ich möchte guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen unseren neuen Patientin vorstellen.
Ja.
Herr Wolfgang Schmidt ist 50 Jahre alt.
Der Patient ist 1,75 m groß und 76 kg schwer.
Der Patient wurde wegen eines Fahrradunfalls per RTW angegriffen.
Mit dem RTW eingeliefert.
Der Patient seien mit dem Fahrrad auf der rechten Seite hingepallen wegen des Nassenboden.
Und er habe seine Handgelenks, sein Knick und sein Abdomain-Berage verletzt.
Die Stärksdischmerkse seien im Handgelenk und die Bewegungen seien angeschränkt.
Außerdem leide der Patient unter Parästhesien, an der Betroffene stelle.
Ja, die Störungsstörung wurde verleichtert.
Die Stärksdischmerkse seien im Handgelenk und die Bewegungen seien in Ruhe beim Drehen und beim Bewegung beim Achten.
Und die Schmerzseien seien dunkel.
Der Patient habe auch im Knie und in den rechten Bauchschmerzen.
Der war hinaus leider der Patient in Exkluationen, an rechten Handelfläche und an rechten Knie.
Die offene Blutungen wurden verleichtert.
Außerdem wurden die Kopf- und Torachstraume verleichtert.
Die restliche Begedeckte der Anamnese, zahm, unauffällig,
hat vorherkrankt, dass die Patient eine arterielle Hypertonie und eine Hypalopidemie
eine entgegenen Migrantin und eine Svan-Zicht-Migrantin ein.
Mit fünf Senioren habe sich der Patient eine Appellectomy unterzogen.
Er habe eine Allergie gegen Polen.
Die Allergie würde sich als Rheumitis oisern.
Der Patient sei vollständig geimpft.
Er hat Rachen und Röbenkonsum.
Er trinkt geregenlich Alkohol.
Er treibt regelmäßig Sport.
Beide bezüglich der Anamnese gab der Patient an,
dass sein Vater eine arterielle Hypertonie leide
und seine Mutter eine Hypozytose und eine arterielle Hypertonie leide.
Der Patient habe eine Gesunde-Schweste.
Sie ist eher seilig und wohne mit seinen Partnern zusammen.
Er habe keine Kinder.
Er sei so der Anta von der Uhr.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben durch die Amnihisten auf einem Handgelenkfraktur
und eine Kniedistortion.
Es kann auch nicht.
Bei den Patienten besteht auch ein Stück Bauchtrauma.
Deswegen würde ich den Patienten untersuchen.
Ich würde auch eine Sonografie durchführen,
um eine Inderungulutung auszuschließen
oder Organutteilung auszuschließen.
Ich würde auch Röntgen-Handgelenk in zwei Ebenen
und Röntgen-Kniegelenk-Rechts in zwei Ebenen
und Röntgen-Kniegelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Ich würde auch ein Flasch-Dichabtas am Anfang
mit den Patienten, mit dem Vitalparametradesparentin,
überprüfen.
Was verstehen Sie unter Vitalparametrad?
Ich werde die Vitalparametradeparamentation
und Herzritmus kontrollieren.
Und Atemfrequenz auch.
Ich würde einen Zugang legen.
Ich werde auch Blutabnehmen, um Blutbild zu kontrollieren.
Ob der Patient eine Blutung hat.
Bevor Sie zum Röntgen schicken,
wollen Sie ein Röntgen durchführen lassen.
Wo hat er am meisten Schmerzen?
Sie denken, dass er ein Radiosfaktor hat.
Wenn man den Verdacht hat,
kann man das vielleicht machen.
Vielleicht ein Schiene.
Bis zum Beweis des Gegenteils.
Bis zum Röntgen alles gut aussieht,
kann man eine Dosale-Gibschiene anlegen.
Auch zur Schmerztherapie.
Dann bewegt sich der Medi-Pilip.
Als Schmerztherapie entlassen.
Mit Gibschiene für 2-3 Tage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Röntgen fahren lassen.
Das haben wir erwähnt.
Röntgen hat zwei Ebenen.
Das ist eine distalle Radiosfaktor.
Was für zwei verschiedene Hauptarten kennen Sie?
Distalle und Radiosfaktor.
Wenn Sie so sagen,
eine distalle Radiosfaktor.
Wie heißt das dann?
Eine distalle Radiosfaktor.
Wenn beide gebrochen sind.
Die distalle unterarmfaktor.
Wenn Ulna Radios ist eine distalle unterarmfaktor.
Wenn Ulna Radios ist eine unterarmfaktor.
Sonst haben wir beide gebrochen.
Wenn das distalle unterarmfaktor.
Würde man das nennen.
Wenn es nur der Radios gebrochen ist.
Da gibt es zwei Typen.
Wobei der eine öfters auftritt.
Die Fraktor als die andere.
Kennen Sie die Unterschiede?
Die Fraktor ist nicht so.
Es gibt zwei Fraktor.
Die sind Kohles und Schmiss.
Die am meisten ist das, was Sie sich gemerkt haben.
Die Kohlesfaktor.
Können Sie das auch anders beschreiben?
Was ist eine Kohlesfaktor?
Die laterale Seite.
Die laterale Seite des Radios.
Die Richtung.
Bei einer Kohlesfaktor.
Aufschützungsfaktor.
Genau.
Man nennt es auch eine Extensionsfaktor.
Das ist eine Flexionsfaktor.
Man kann sich das gut merken.
Eine Extensionsfaktor.
Wenn Sie daum dorthin, ist eine C.
Also Kohles.
Das ist eine Kohlesfaktor.
Anderes ist eine Schmissfaktor.
Eine Distalle Radios Extensionsfaktor.
Wir machen keine Facharztprüfung.
Aber ich wollte das mal so erwähnen.
Danke.
Im Kniegelenk.
Das habe ich nicht ganz rausgehört.
Hat er Bewegungseinschränkungen?
Nein.
Der Patient hat keine Bewegungseinschränkungen.
Aber er hat leichtes Ödämen.
Und Exkursions auf der Patella.
Das ist eine Art.
Ich weiß nicht, was euch beigebracht wird.
Aber in der Klinik sagt man selten eine Exkursion.
Man sagt einfach eine Schürfunde.
Weiß nicht, wie in der Prüfung bei euch das gemacht wird.
Aber wir in der Klinik haben auch gesagt,
das ist eine Schürfunde, nicht eine Exkursionshunde.
Das ist bestimmt richtig.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es geht.
Dann können Sie mir sagen,
ob Sie haben gesagt, der rechte Bauch tut weh.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eine stumfe Bauchtauma.
Haben Sie dort eine Wunde gesehen?
Oder eine Stichverletzung im Bauch?
Ich habe nicht gesehen.
Ich habe danach gefragt,
aber der Patient hat das nicht geschaut.
Ich werde bei der Attrapage untersuchen.
Ich werde schauen.
Sie haben vorhin erwähnt,
ich würde ein Ultraschall untersuchen machen.
Worauf achtet man eher?
Kann man eine Daranfälle zum Beispiel sehen?
Nein, aber kann man...
Ich sage nicht, aber organisch.
Ich habe auch gesagt,
ich wollte Sie darstellen.
Wir können leber,
leber und mit
mit einer Sonographie
sehr gut...
Die Niere gehört auch dazu.
Und die Niere gehört auch dazu.
Ich kann auch die Flüssigkeit
leber teilen.
Ob es eine Blutung vorliegt?
Ja, die Flüssigkeit,
wenn man das ein bisschen...
die freie Flüssigkeit nennt man das.
Das heißt nicht,
dass man das nicht...
Sie sind vielleicht aufgeregt, das alles gut.
Das erste, was man guckt,
ist, ob man Freiflüssigkeit hat.
Dann geht man über die Schnelldauer,
organisch, leber, mit
Niere, ob da eine Auffälligkeit da ist.
Wenn eine Aufkälligkeit wäre,
auch wenn da kein Schmerz ist,
was würden Sie dann veranlassen?
Ich würde
die Blutung kontrollieren.
Wir gehen jetzt davon aus,
wenn Sie im Ultraschall sehen,
dass z.B. Auffälligkeit im Nieren
oder im Leber oder irgendwo
eine Auffälligkeit ist.
Dann lebe ich eine CT rein.
Da bringe ich schnell in eine CT rein.
Mit einer CT können wir feststellen,
dass es eine Verletzung gibt.
Oder wie schwer die Verletzung ist.
Man kann es besser einschätzen.
Man muss dringend einen Zug angelegt werden.
Ansonsten,
fürs Handgelenk haben wir gesprochen,
das ist relativ okay.
Bis auf diese Bunde.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Vielleicht kann ich eine Prälung
für den Kniegelenk?
Das hätte ich zuerst gesagt.
Er hat eine Kniegelenk-Prälung.
Mit einer Schürfunde.
Der finanzielle Diagnose könnte man auch
eine Disturzionstrauma denken.
Aber eher eine Prälung.
Richtig.
Das ist ein Stumpfen-Bauftrauma.
Der Verdacht eines Beswarnjahres
sagt, dass es tut er weh.
Der Verdacht muss man ausschließen.
Durch Untersuchungen.
Laboer.
Das ist eine Stumpfen-Bauftrauma.
Gut.
Der Patient.
Der Kniegelenk.
Als Therapie-Empfehlung.
Nach der klinischen Untersuchung.
Sie haben einen Kniegerünsch ausgeschlossen.
Sie haben gesehen,
dass die Kapselbandapparat stabil ist.
Kein Kniegelenk.
Und im Handgelenk
sehen Sie eine Distalloradius-Extensionsfraktur.
Ohne Wesen- und Distellation.
Und Ultraschall.
Und im Labor.
Haben Sie alles unauffällig gewesen.
Zyklisch das auch Thomas.
Was empfinden Sie?
Ich schulde eine konservative Tätschung.
Ich habe eine Konzertie.
Ich schulde eine konservative Therapie entwählen.
Und zwar Kühlung, Schaumung und Hochladung.
Und wir leben auch ein...
Was würden Sie kühlen, schon hochladen?
Der Patient sollte sein Handgelenk
hochlegen.
Die Organe.
Und die Organe.
Soll er sein Bauch kühlen?
Nein.
Das Handgelenk und die.
Warum nicht?
Da kann man auch kühlen.
Mit Schmerzen kann noch entwickeln.
Das kann sein, dass die Schmerzen kommen.
Man muss nicht warten, bis die Schmerzen kommen.
Die Schmerzen kommen.
Schmerztherapie ist auch wichtig.
Wir sollten eine
Nanztheroid-Antirolematik verschreiben.
Wir werden auch Gips anlegen.
Wir werden auch eine
Gips-Verband.
Es gibt zwei grobe Art von Gips.
Entweder gibt es eine zirkuläre Gips.
Eine Gipschiene.
Eine halbe Schiene.
Eine Gipschiene wird oft genutzt.
Oder eine zirkuläre Gips.
Man darf eine Zirkuläre Gips dranmachen.
Bei flischen Traumern.
Es gibt eine Partman-Syndrom-Surfer-Meelle.
Es gibt eine zirkuläre Gips.
Sondern es gibt eineKeep-Schiene.
6 Wochen haben wir keine Zirkuläre Gips.
6 Wochen habe ich doch noch.
6 Wochen haben wir eine Gipschiene.
6 Wochen lang?
Ja, oder nicht.
oder nicht? Ist es stabil die Gipschiene? Was ist stabiler? Gipschiene oder einen
Zirkulären Gips? Zirkulären Gips stabiler als Gipschiene.
Also, wann würde man das machen? Nach einer Weile muss man wieder, ja, Zirkulär Gips vielleicht.
Fühlen schon hoch lagern bis zur Abschwellung, wenn das abgespollen ist, in der Regel so etwa
einer Woche etwa, kann mehr oder weniger sein. Nach abschwellender Maßnahmen, Kontrollen Gips,
regelmäßig Gipskontrollen, kann man einen zirkulären Gips anlegen, sozusagen.
Okay. Und dann insgesamt bis sechs Wochen vor Stromer rückstellen, sozusagen, und Röntgenkontrollen
machen und die Gips wieder abnehmen und dann wahrscheinlich noch krank gymnasiek danach.
Okay. Was würden Sie noch machen? Also das ist Handgelenk, Kniegelenk. Was würden Sie mit den
Früchten machen? Die Wunden, die ich ja mit dem Fahrrad gefallen, Schriftwunden. Würden Sie auch versorgen?
Ja. Mit Desfektionsmittel. Die Wunden reinigen, ob da Fremdkörper sind.
Ja, natürlich. Das infiziere ich.
Und wenn da Fremdkörper ist, wie kleine Sandkörner oder Steinchen, die auch entfernen und der Rihl verbinden.
Ja, okay.
Genau, der Tanner Schutz haben Sie gefragt, muss man jetzt nicht aufregen, das war vor zwei Jahren.
Ja.
Würden Sie noch etwas spielen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also, man kann zum Beispiel den Patienten fehlen, weil es ein stumpfem Bauchdrauma ist, eine Verletzung, die jetzt nicht da ist, kann ja noch entstehen.
Würde man den Patienten vielleicht empfehlen, dass er einen Tag stationär im Krankenhaus bleibt, dass wir den am nächsten Tag nochmal Laborkontrollen,
nochmal klinisch untersucht, wie es im Bauch ist, was noch nicht ist, kann ja noch werden.
Ja.
Das ist vielleicht da, dass man eine innere Verletzung hat. Man kann natürlich nie garantieren, ob das in zwei, drei Tagen doch noch Blut oder nicht.
Aber stattdessen gesehen, wenn eine Blutung oder eine Problematik da ist, am nächsten Tag würde man nochmal Labor abnehmen,
Laborkontrollen, klinisch untersuchen, eventuell nochmal Ultraschall untersuchen machen.
Und wenn da alles okay ist und der keine Klinik hat, könnte man den dann konservativ nach Hause entlassen, bezüglich der Reihung.
Und bei Wiederauffälligkeit wieder vorstellen.
Okay.
Okay, Dok.
Das war es meinerseits. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ich habe nicht. Aber vielleicht die anderen Kollegen.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Sie haben ja keine, haben Sie...
Was zu ergänzen?
Entschuldigen.
Ihre Erfahrung.
Ich würde der Kollegin, wenn Sie erlauben, Herr Meister, wenn Sie erlauben, würden wir ihr einen Zeug des Geben.
Danke sehr.
Aber ich würde auch negative Dinge hören.
Auch negative?
Ja.
Also, was ist negativ?
Sie konnten schon, das heißt so, manchmal so paar, ich kann es jetzt nicht sagen, welche Sätze das sind, aber sie sind sehr gut bilden.
Und...
Okay, Sie haben auch gegliedert, einigermaßen alles, hat eigentlich gut gelaufen.
Kann ich jetzt in der Nachhinein sein, weil jetzt 20 Minuten vorbei sind.
Ich habe mir irgendwelche Notizen gemacht, aber das Rückstellen hätte man machen können, wenn einer ein Trauma hat.
Das erste, was man macht ist, wenn Stufe Bauchtrauma, also mehrere Probleme ist, Politrauma, dann würde man Zugang legen.
Und dann Ultraschall, so ein Fast Track, also Ultraschall-Untersuchung machen, den Handgelenk Rückstellen und so weiter, wenn keine frei Flüssigkeit da ist.
Das ist wichtiger als das Handgelenk, wenn da erstmal so eine Grafisch untersuchen, weil wenn jemand blutet, ist es schlimmer, wenn der Handgelenk hat dann nur Schmerz.
Die Reihenfolge würde ich setzen, dass der Zuganggeläumung bekommt, Ultraschall-Untersuchung des Bauches, gleichzeitig der Anamnese weiterführen.
Und wenn Ultraschall alles okay ist, dann Handgelenkschiene anlegen und dann zu Röntgen schicken, Kniegelenk und das Handgelenk in zwei Ebenen durchschöpfen lassen.
Wenn im Bauch fragliche Sachen sind, dann direkt ins City fahren.
Ultraschall-Untersuchung ist wichtiger als das Handgelenk in dem Moment.
Man muss Zeit geben, wenn man da wartet und sagt, Elisabeth, kannst du mal bitte mal die Gipschiene anlegen?
Moment, ich hole das erstmal und dann geht es Zeit vorbei.
Es gibt auch in der Regel, wenn ein RTW kommt und da es Verdacht eines Handgelenkens muss,
in der Regel hat er auch eine unterarmt Schiene, so eine ganz grobe Schiene draufgelegt,
so ein fertiges Verband, nichts so Spezielles, hat er eigentlich schon rückgestellt.
Deswegen hätte ich vielleicht erwähnen können, der RTW hat es beim Handgelenk rückgestellt.
Das war mein Fehler vielleicht.
In der Regel, wenn jemand mit RTW kommt, dann machen wir das schon.
Aber so ein, ich weiß nicht mal wie es heißt, auch eine Schiene letztendlich angelegt,
die schnell angelegt werden kann.
Und wenn das sich bestätigt, dann kann man dann ein richtiger Gipschiene, so ein Cast, anlegen.